as the death count mounts Democrats
launched investigations into the Trump
administration's coronavirus response
Bernie just won't drop out and the Trump
team prepares to target Joe Biden I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is brought to you
by expressvpn don't leave your internet
unprotected go check out go check them
out and express it VPN calm / pendants
expressvpn calm / man well obviously we
have tons of news to get to today so
let's just begin it's all bad I'm just
gonna put that out there right now not a
lot of good news to report to you here
today this is gonna be a rough rough
couple of weeks as president from said
could be a rough month hopefully it's
only a rough month and not beyond them
the latest death count in the United
States is over 5,100 yesterday we saw in
excess of a thousand deaths in the
United States from coronavirus in Italy
in excess of 720 deaths in Spain in
excess of 900 deaths in France in excess
of 500 deaths in the UK nearly 600
deaths so this thing is beginning to
spike in terms of death across the West
the question is when it Peaks how long
that peak lasts whether the summer kills
it off the stats are ugly at this point
they're going to get ugly over the next
couple of weeks because as we identify
new cases there's a time delay between
when the cases are identified and when
people actually die from this stuff
meanwhile we're hearing reports that the
death toll in even countries that are
being open like Italy might be greatly
undercounted according to The Wall
Street Journal margarita Stein Katya and
Eric Silver's reporting in the town of
cocoa leo in hours drive east of here
the local nursing home is out east of
Milan a local nursing home lost over a
third of its residents in March
none of the 24 people who died that were
tested for coronavirus nor were the 38
people who died in another nursing home
in the nearby town of Lodi these are not
isolated incidents Italy's official
death toll from the virus stands at
13,000 155 the most of any country in
the world but that number tells only
part of the story because many people
who died from the virus don't make it to
the hospital and are never tested so
just as I've been saying all along there
are tons and tons of people who aren't
being tested who have corn virus and are
not dying there are also tons of people
who are dying and are not being tested
because by the time they die it's too
late to test them they're not at the
hospital
most people dying outside the hospital
so probably the estimates go that may be
twice as many people are dead in Italy
as we already know about meanwhile
over at the White House experts are
apparently telling the White House that
research is showing corona virus can be
spread not just by sneeze or coughs
which should create that six foot radius
that you're supposed to be outside of
but also just by talking or possibly
even breathing which is just wonderful
and does suggest that everyone's an
idiot for suggesting we shouldn't be
wearing face masks full-time well the
current corona virus specific research
is limited the results of available
studies are consistent with
aerosolization of virus from normal
breathing according to the letter
written by dr. Harvey Fineberg chairman
of a committee with the National Academy
of Sciences Feinberg says that he will
start wearing a mask when he goes to the
grocery store he's I'm not gonna wear a
surgical mask clinicians it needs need
those but have a nice western-style
bandana I might wear or I have a ba ba
balaclava had some pretty nice options
and doctor foul she told CNN on Tuesday
the idea of recommending broad use of
masks in the u.s. to prevent spread of
corona virus is under very active
discussion by the group which of course
is not a great shock it's just that for
weeks they've been telling us nobody
should wear a mask it's actually
counterproductive and a waste of time
meanwhile foreign countries like Israel
have been mandating that everyone
everybody wear masks when they go into
public aerosolization is basically
worst-case scenario for the passage of a
virus there there are a few different
ways that viruses can get passed if it's
like Ebola then it has to be passed
directly through bodily liquid if you
are if you are looking at what the
original perception of coronal virus was
then it could be passed by coughing
right larger droplets that land on
somebody's face and then get into their
nose or mouth aerosolization is you
breathe it stays in the air we don't
know how long stays in the air you
breathe the air I mean it's just it's
its worst case it really is really
terrible news so among the there's a
reason that Eric Garcetti who I will as
you will see a little bit later on in
the program we're gonna go through the
timeline here Eric Garcetti the mayor of
Los Angeles on Wednesday he called on
the city's millions of residents to
start covering their faces whenever they
are out in public as part of the effort
to combat the outbreak of the novel
coronavirus he tweeted early data
suggests many who are infected are not
symptomatic which is why we are
recommending use cloth face coverings
plus physical distancing for essential
activities do not your surgical a95
masks which are reserved for first
responders and medical workers well if
you already have one you can wear them
obviously but if you my wife is a
medical worker she hasn't and then if
I'm asked at home that's kind of a
different thing if you if you don't have
n 95 masks then you shouldn't be taking
those away from medical workers because
there's a short supply of them
meanwhile we're learning from the New
York Times that the federal government's
stock of protective medical supplies is
nearly gone we'll get to that in just
one second so lots of good news out
there and I'm allowed to I mean lots of
horrible news out there it makes you
want to stamp in crawling at home which
you should be doing anyway
well I at least have one piece of good
news for you while you are curling up at
home and that is you could be in the
world's most comfortable gear you're
really going to appreciate your time you
John underwear when you're just sitting
around the house or putzing around the
house during your gardening doing the
cleaning in the back room for that
reason Tommy John the revolutionary
lounge where an underwear brand that's
redefining comfort is offering you 20%
off site-wide you heard right for a
limited time all customers get 20% off
site-wide plus free shipping treat
yourself upgrade to a few pairs of Tommy
John underwear in the softest most
breathable fabrics you've ever worn by
the way great for men great for women
and my wife has Tommy John products as
well she absolutely loves them their
underwear comes back no wedgie guarantee
which would have helped me a lot back in
high school a vision they've limited
visible panty lines eliminated visible
panty lines for women their quickdraw
fly has been proven to save men over 217
minutes a year I don't know how they did
those studies for a limited time go to
Tommy John comm / Ben a 20% off
site-wide plus free shipping that is
Tommy John comm / Ben for 20% off
site-wide plus the free shipping Tommy
John comm / ben if you're gonna treat
yourself treat yourself to something
you're gonna be using like every day
while we all wait for this horrific
situation to end you're at home anyway
you may as well lounge around and
comfort and style do it at Tommy John
Calm / Ben and get 20% off site-wide
that's Tommy John comm / Ben okay so the
the federal supplies are apparently in
short supply according to the New York
Times the federal government has nearly
emptied its emergency stockpile of
protected medical supplies as state
governors continue to plead for
protective gear for desperate Hospital
workers according to a senior
administration official the official
said that the FEMA the FEMA stockpile
has delivered more than eleven point six
million n95 masks 5.2 million face
shields - 22 million gloves 7140
ventilators exhausting the emergency
stockpile the official said there was a
tiny slice of her personal protective
equipment leftover that is being
preserved for emergency medical workers
for the federal government while there's
no more personal protective equipment in
the stockpile left over for the states
apparently the administration still has
more than 90
400 ventilators ready to be deployed
Governor Andrew Cuomo said on Wednesday
the only hope for a state at this point
is the federal government's capacity to
deliver he said you have a shortfall on
gallons American companies can make
gallons and not like wedding yet it's
like paper gowns make the gowns make the
gloves make the masks you know why are
we running out of these basic supplies
well honestly that is a serious question
for like Andrew Cuomo you're the donor
of the state why weren't you prepared
like III will say I am absolutely
bewildered by the notion that the
federal government is the first line of
defense against this sort of stuff
because guess what it actually is not
like like Gavin Newsom is the governor
of my state California and he's awful I
mean Gavin Newsom came out yesterday and
he said this is an opportunity to get
progressive priorities done in
California because that's really if
you're thinking of a pandemic is an
opportunity to get progressive
priorities done you're doing being a
human being wrong we do not consent to
the complete rewriting of the bargain
between governments and individuals on
the basis of a government failure to
prepare for and respond to a global
pandemic sorry no the answer is no you
don't get to rewrite the entire
constitutional bargain on the basis of a
Black Swan event that you guys honestly
should have prepared for and then
responded to in the crappiest possible
way but Gavin Newsom did say something
that I think is a valuable reminder
which is that the first line of defense
in these situations is States you're
seeing it handling handled differently
state by state Larry Hogan in Maryland
is doing an excellent job Mike DeWine
you know hi oh he's doing an excellent
job and gavin newsom in terms of
actually getting the supplies is doing a
pretty good job in getting no credit
because andrew cuomo's from new york and
the media or new york-based they like
the fact that Cuomo is sitting there and
railing it at the feds to give him more
stuff but gavin newsom yesterday's with
jake tapper he said listen we've got
millions of mass we got millions of
masks we are a state very powerful state
and the number of NASA provided to us by
the federal government is it drop in the
bucket compared to what we ourselves had
actually procured here's governor Gavin
Newsom we're blessed here in California
with purchasing power that's second only
to the federal government we've ordered
101 million n95 masks I've been able to
distribute thirty five point four
million n95 masks I'll put it in
perspective it's not a critique it's
just an observation all of the
deliveries from the national stockpile
and there been three total 1 million 89
thousand and 95 masks
we've distributed 35 plus million so
gives you a sense that states are
getting a little bit of support the
gonna have to be resourceful okay well
but that that's what states are designed
to do again it's usually public health
crises in which states are supposed to
step into the breach so good for Newsom
I mean it's important to keep those
stats in mind cuz the the national media
being national in scope rarely focus on
where the real issues are which are the
look at the local and state levels and
what's one of the things has been so
weird about this crisis is that there
are hot spots all around the country and
it's being treated as though the federal
government is the first line of defense
for a local for a local hot spot now the
federal government is definitely one of
the lines of defense but the first line
of defense Trump said this got all sorts
of crap for it the first line of defense
is your local government and then it is
the state government and then it is the
federal government the principle of
subsidiarity does not actually disappear
federalism did not disappear just
because there's a national crisis right
the fact is that Gavin Newsom himself is
talking about how he procured 35 times
the number of n95 masks as the governor
of the state of California that the
federal government has distributed to
the entire country that's the way this
is supposed to work so it's really in
you want to judge a governor on how he's
doing how about you judge him on how
he's actually obtaining the gear himself
rather than how much he yells to the
media about how he needs help from the
federal government and calling for help
from the federal government I'm not
saying it's unnecessary it may very well
be necessary what I'm saying is that we
judge you as a governor based on what
you do for your state and that one of
the elements of that is yelling at the
federal government and the other 99
percent of the job is not yelling at the
federal government it's getting things
done meanwhile there are reports scary
reports that some of the ventilators are
actually going to fail in the in the
national stockpile that the the
ventilators in the national stockpile
are not in great shape according to the
New York Times president Trump has
repeatedly assured Americans the federal
government is holding 10,000 ventilators
in reserve to ship to the hardest hit
hospitals around the nation as they
struggle to keep the most critically ill
patients alive already in New York
they're experiencing shortages of
ventilators we had on doctor Marty
Meharry from Johns Hopkins University
yesterday he mentioned that in New York
hospitals they already splitting
ventilators which is never the preferred
methodology you can't control the
airflow back into the lungs the same way
that you could if you were not splitting
the ventilator so the sort of shortages
that were predicted those predictions
apparently were correct right I was
wondering whether those predictions were
correct because originally they said
beginning of last week the hospitals
were gonna be able to run apparently the
overrun has already begun in New York
City and we are only on April 2nd
ventilators in the federal government
stockpile are not all operational
according to the New York Times federal
officials have neglected to mention that
thousands more of life-saving devices
are unavailable after the contract to
maintain the government's stockpile
elapsed late last summer and a
contracting dispute meant that a new
firm did not begin its work until late
January by then the corona virus crisis
was already underway the revelation came
in response to enquiries to the
Department of Health and Human Services
after state officials reported that some
of the ventilators they received were
not operational which stoked speculation
the administration had not kept up with
the task of maintaining the stockpile in
fact the contract of the company that
was maintaining the machines expired at
the end of last summer a contract
protest delayed handing the job to
agility a Minneapolis based provider of
medical services and equipment Angele D
was not given the 38 million dollar task
until late January when the scope of the
global coronavirus crisis was first
becoming clear it's not known whether
problems with the ventilators predated
the contract lapse maintenance and
machines did halt that delay became a
potentially deadly lapse unclear what
exactly was why the contract lapse from
this report or what that contract
dispute meant or what the contract
protest was bottom line is that the
number of operational ventilator is
actually lower than the federal
government has been saying meanwhile the
New York City virus death toll has
neared 1,400 Mayor Bill DeBlasio the
most incompetent mayor in America has
said that April 5th was the demarcation
line in the corona virus fight and he
gave some stats he said that the city
still needs 3.3 million and 95 masks 2.1
million surgical masks a hundred
thousand isolation gowns and 400
additional ventilators apparently de
Blasio has said the James O'Neal the
former police commissioner who's now an
executive with Visa was actually
returning to the government to oversee
operations and logistics related to the
virus outbreak de Blasio said New York
would continue to have great need for
supplies well after Sunday by the end of
April he estimated the healthcare system
would need 65 thousand additional
hospital beds to accommodate new virus
patients as well as the people to staff
them the city's public hospital system
plans to convert this the New York Times
all of its facilities to an all of them
to ICU units officials said adding the
supplies and personnel were crucial to
increasing the number of ICU beds
patients who do not have the virus will
be sent to large-scale temporary
hospitals like the one setup at Javits
Convention Center our hotel is converted
into temporary medical facilities so
basically all of the hospitals turn into
ICU beds all these ancillary beds turn
into
ICU beds de Blasio says that the goal is
within reach the actually the the region
itself has passed 2,000 deaths total New
York New Jersey Connecticut well about
220 400 deaths at this hour meanwhile
hospitals and doctors are feeling a
financial squeeze because it turns out
that one of the ways the doctors make
their money is by performing surgeries
for example and coronavirus patients
don't actually pay that much as compared
to surgeries this is not a case for
nationalized health care okay people are
getting the care and the insurance
companies are waiving the cost it does
mean if there is financial squeeze and
financial squeeze is not a shock
obviously this is another area where the
government is gonna have to step in if
you're talking about bailing industries
out and making sure that people get paid
on time the doctors and nurses would be
the people who you are most worried
about at this point governors of elite
in at least 17 states have halted or
urged hospitals to stop elective
procedures in recent weeks hospitals
themselves have canceled surgeries to
clear space for expected coronavirus
patients and preserve scarce protective
equipment many patients have decided to
avoid medical settings obey government
stay at home orders that means income to
the hospitals are has been dropping
extraordinarily fast Williamson West
Virginia is at the risk of losing its
facility will into Memorial Hospital
just as the virus is expected to spread
the hospital said it would close its
doors in April after revenue dropped 45
percent in March visits the emergency
room fell by about a third in patient
days dropped by two-thirds had gene
pressed an instrument executive of the
76 bed hospital the hospital is still
operating in bankruptcy and has secured
financing intended to keep it open until
a buyer took over the new pressure meant
that the money would not be enough
bottom line is that under emergency
circumstances bailing out some of these
less successful hospitals is going to be
necessary just to ensure that everybody
can still get the medical care they need
and before everybody starts screaming
about how nationalized health care would
save us let me just point to Italy Spain
the UK France
everyone's overrun everyone is overrun
okay and this is this is not a
referendum on the medical system it I
mean the fact is that we have better
doctors and better nurses and better
registered better respiratory therapists
and nearly any place on earth have
better health facilities than public
health facilities than virtually any
place on earth this is a Black Swan
event it's obviously a Black Swan event
our doctors and nurses are exhausted
over one it's a full on it's full on
disaster area and as we will see this
was not predicted by anyone it was not
predicted by anyone okay there when I
say not anyone there are a few
exceptions people who took this with
grave concern a few members of both
parties Tom cotton comes to mind on the
Republican side of the aisle governor
chris murphy of connecticut he comes to
mine on the other side of the aisle but
overall no one expected scale and scope
like this okay overall and we're gonna
trace that timeline because believe it
or not this is getting politicized
almost immediately well gets you more of
this in just one second first we do work
with a ton of sponsors on this program
is you have noticed whose products they
believe could be a value and interest to
our audience and we share this view
that's why we're glad to speak about
them and endorse them and talk about how
great they are we understand also that
our partner sponsorship doesn't
necessarily imply sponsorship or
endorsement of the views we express I
mean that's the way it always works with
advertisers just cuz somebody advertises
on the program doesn't mean they agree
with everything I say hell I don't agree
with everything that I say half the time
with that in mind we are so glad to
welcome back as a sponsor to the show
quip quip offers simple affordable
surprisingly enjoyable oral oral care
for everyone they want you to know that
what matters most when it comes to good
oral care is good habits it's really
easy under current circumstances to
really let yourself go and not do the
teeth brushing that you're supposed to
you know stop stop the flossing and stop
the oral care no now quip is making it
easy for you and they're delivering at
erect your door so you never have to go
to the pharmacy again which is a good
way to avoid what's going on outside
your door so here's what you should do
brush for 2 minutes twice a day floss
regularly no matter what brand you use
quip makes that simple starting with an
electric toothbrush refillable floss in
the anti cavity toothpaste clips
electric brush it has sensitive sonic
vibrations built-in timer 30-second
pulses to guide a full and even clean
and kind of buzzes every 30 seconds so
you know that you've done the quadrant
plus quip delivers fresh brush head
floss and toothpaste refills to your
door every three months free shipping so
your routine is always right joint over
3 million healthy mouths get clipped
today starting at $25 if you go to get
quip comm slash up hero right now you
get your first refill for free as your
first refill free at get quip comm slash
up hero that is GE tqu IP comm slash
Shapiro quip is the good habits come in
and keep those good habits going even in
the midst of a really rough time in fact
that's when it's most important to keep
good habits going meanwhile how is the
federal government responding to all of
this well there's a lot of talk about
mass public testing how in order for us
to even gauge how we end this thing we
have to have mass public testing dr.
Burks dr. deborah birx she says we need
antibody tests as fast as possible to
determine who's already had this thing
so they can go back out there and work
again and one of the big questions is
how we transition from the complete
shutdown economy back to something that
remotely resembles a normal economy that
has gained additional additional sort of
urgency given the fact that the u.s.
weekly jobless claims doubled to 6.6
million last week that means that over
the last two weeks two weeks 10 million
Americans have filed for unemployment 10
million Americans to put that by way of
contrast the previous high week was 650
mm okay in two weeks we have lost 10
million jobs in the American economy
that is not because of coronavirus
purely that is because a forcible
shutdown from the federal government and
state government of nearly every
business in America and it turns out
that contrary to be popular Bernie
Sanders belief business owners do not
have piles of cash lying in the back
room that they are storing away from
their employees that's not the way any
of this works they reinvest in their
business they invest in their employees
and that means that everybody is is
relying on additional income relying on
revolving credit lines relying on the
continuation of the economies when the
economy is forcibly stopped dead when
the economy hits a brick wall the way
that the government has made it hit a
brick wall that means the jobs fall off
extraordinarily extraordinarily fast and
that is what is happening right here and
that's why the government is justified
in filling the gap and it's why you are
justified in taking the money it is not
welfare for you to take money when the
government drives in a Ford f-150s I've
said a thousand times the government
Rove a Ford f-150 through the front door
of your house they now have to pay you
for driving a Ford f-150 through the
door of your house maybe they had a
reason for doing it that was proper I
think they probably did but that does
not mean they don't have to compensate
you for that the government also has a
reason for paving your house over and
building a highway that doesn't mean
they get to seize your property and not
pay you for it this is the takings
Clause of the Fifth Amendment they have
completely removed your property from
you and your ability to work and they
have to pay you for that privilege at
least until the ability to receive a job
renews itself but obviously the urgency
here is extraordinary we cannot allow
this to go on for months on end we
certainly
allow this to be the rationale for
rewriting the entire bargain between
governments and the American people as I
mentioned earlier governor Gavin Newsom
in California he's been saying that this
is a time to get progressive priorities
done by hell it is it's the time to make
sure that Americans don't die that we
can all get back to work you're starting
to see this kind of nonsense from Chuck
Schumer too he says you know during the
next infrastructure package I want green
infrastructure really like this this is
your push right now is that we need to
build some freaking solar panels we got
ten million Americans who just lost
their jobs in the last two week by the
way not in the solar panel industry here
is here is Chuck Schumer being a fool
COBIT for can probably be more forward
looking at the economy and if we're
going to do infrastructure because
there's nothing better than getting the
infrastructure going and going in a big
strong way we need it big we needed bold
and we need a futuristic which means
green there's traditional infrastructure
roads bridges highways we need that but
we also need new green infrastructure
these people cannot wait to spend your
money they cannot wait to spend money
that does not exist we have spent six
trillion with a T trillion dollars more
the entire GDP of the United States well
let's see more the federal government
spends four trillion dollars a year the
entire GDP of the United States at 20
trillion dollars a year so we've spent
in one third of the entire GDP in the
last in the last three weeks in the last
two weeks and they're already going like
can we need two trillion dollars on
random infrastructure jobs that will not
materialize and we need but and again
the infrastructure traps are not the
problem are you gonna social existence
while you do the infrastructure jobs the
question is not government jobs here the
question is how do we get people back to
their regular jobs
I mean I'm producer Colton you feel like
going out and working on a road right
now like is that is that exactly what it
will do or panels okay you have a job
they're a bunch of people out there who
don't have jobs they want their old jobs
back they don't want to go work a road
like that's not a substitute for
anything and again you haven't solved
the underlying problem which is the
corona virus pandemic nobody wants to go
out and work right now in the middle of
a corona virus pandemic you can offer
people Road jobs right now and they're
not gonna go take them because the
underlying problem has not been solved
and yet the Democrats cannot wait to
spend more of your money in some
Republicans to Mitch McConnell good for
him he says that we should move slowly
on considering any follow up legislation
he's going to ignore efforts by Nancy
Pelosi to jumpstart talks she cannot
wait
to spend more money McConnell said she
needs to stands out on the notion we're
gonna go along with taking advantage of
the crisis to do things that are
unrelated to the crisis nonetheless she
says the victims of the corona virus
pandemic cannot wait
it is moving faster than the leader may
have suspected even he has said some
things should wait for the next bill I
hope we can work in a four corners
manner for the common good again this is
this is people trying to take advantage
of a horrible situation in order to try
and promote their own political
priorities and we don't have the money
for that okay we literally have no money
left all the money is gone the money is
gone right now we are on the verge of
just printing money that's where we are
the federal government in order to
uphold the value of global currency has
been buying back our bonds and injecting
dollars into the global economy that's
what the Federal Reserve is doing right
now the Treasury Department is doing
this okay at a certain point you think
there's a tremendous market for American
bonds as we continue to shovel money out
the door on random projects what we need
to be doing right now is expediting the
money that we've already passed to get
in the hands of people we need the Small
Business Administration coordinating
better with bangs so you can get those
loans on the same day we were promised
that if you walked into a bank and you
provided your documentation you're gonna
get it alone the same day and banks were
like no that's not right you can't do
that like we actually need it might take
three days it might take four days the
government has been lying about this
okay the government has been saying that
you're gonna receive checks forth with
state unemployment programs are not up
to this they're just not up to the task
they're taking weeks to get to people
this is why you're seeing food banks
being overrun is why I mean how about
Congress focuses on the stuff they
should be focused on making sure that
the money that they just shoveled out
the door actually gets to the people it
is supposed to get to right now wouldn't
that be the major concern also making
sure the banks are backed so that they
don't pull in their loans you know
floating them in the loan so they don't
get those bang then they don't float
they don't pull back in your loan and
foreclose on your house right so the
Federal Reserve on Wednesday eased rules
around how banks account for their super
safe assets and move men to boost the
flow of credit to cash-strapped
consumers and businesses during the
chronovisor shutdown the Fed said it
would exclude for one year Treasuries
and deposits held at the central bank
from a banks supplementary leverage
ratio calculation the ratio measures
capital funds the banks raised from
investors earned through profits and
used to absorb losses as a
you've loans and other assets in other
words by law if you take money from the
federal if you borrow from the Federal
Reserve you have to have a certain
amount of cash on hand they're starting
or Treasuries on hand they're starting
to loosen those rules so that you can
actually get loans from the bank to
float your business for the moment and
that stuff that needs to be done it
needs to be done right now but but
focusing on green infrastructure or how
you can change the bargain that that's
not what we should be focused on and you
know credit to Andrew Cuomo he's
actually talking in realistic terms
about what we need to be focused on
beyond this and that is how do we
prevent something like this from
happening again honestly he was musing
about this aloud yesterday Andrew Cuomo
I've been critical of Andrew Cuomo's
media coverage like I think that Cuomo
has been ok I mean he's been
substantially better than gavin newsom I
certainly don't think he's been better
than Mike DeWine in Ohio he's in
particularly excellent job with Larry
Hogan and Maryland he's been very very
good
but Cuomo has the adoration of the media
cuz he's in New York
but his musing on what needs to happen
after this is not the wrong music like
our government still has not figured out
how to stop something like this from
happening again
and by the way when we say it could
happen again I mean like in September
because there could very easily be a
second wave of this all the studies that
are being trotted out right now do not
take into account a second wave in
September they don't I asked several
scientists about this yesterday several
doctors and epidemiologists so those
estimates where we're seeing 100,000 to
240,000 dead that could be by August
gang that doesn't mean a year from now
that means by like at the end of August
anyway here's Andrew Cuomo musing about
how do we stop something like this from
happening again that's the question we
all need answered right now not can we
build a windmill at Ohio Chuck Schumer
here's Andrew Cuomo we're never going to
be the same again we're not going to
forget what happened here the fear that
we have the anxiety that we have that's
not just going to go away when do we get
back to normal I don't think we get back
to normal I think we get back or we we
get to a new normal so how how we come
out of this and making sure that it's
positive and not negative how do we
learn from this and how do we grow from
this okay that really is the question
but don't worry don't worry guys the
actual
that Democrats want to ask is how can we
blame from for this how can blame from
for this because right now we're gonna
do the hindsight is twenty-twenty
routine now yesterday I tweeted
something out I got a lot of flack from
folks on the left I tweeted out that
President Trump did a bad job in the
early days of this because he did do a
not good job in the early days of this
and I said so did mostly everyone else
now that doesn't mean they did an
equally bad job or talked about this in
equally a bad way but there are
gradations of how seriously people took
this and what I basically said is nobody
took this incredibly incredibly
seriously until early March and people
went nuts no we all took it super
seriously all the way back in the late
January we took it super seriously going
all the way back okay let's define super
seriously because let's let's talk about
what exactly has been necessitated
millions of tests millions of tests
right across the country shutdowns of
all public events shutdowns of ability
to gather mask-wearing antibody tests
vaccinations development you know like
actual measures that would have been
taking it super seriously do you
remember any time in February Democrats
calling for exactly the measures we've
taken in March do you remember any of
that I don't do you remember the damage
you remember Democrats opposing
President Trump saying that that we
should not allow travel from China I
remember that so here let's let's go
through the timeline because again not
everyone was equivalently head in the
sand about this not everyone was
equivalently dismissive of this and I
generally agree with the idea that in
the early days Trump was far too
dismissive of this thing I think that's
true I think they're also Democrats like
Bill DeBlasio who's the epicenter of
this thing who are super dismissive and
I have a question for all the folks on
the Left who are really questioning you
know Trump was so dismissive
he was so dismissive and we were taking
it seriously really I don't remember all
your criticism of Bill DeBlasio in the
epicenter of this thing who was spending
weeks on end telling people to go out in
public but I want to trace the timeline
here because I think it's accurate to
get this timeline down we'll get to that
in just one moment cuz I think it's it
we have to be honest about this the
reason is not as a defense of President
Trump the reason is because there's a
narrative that is being set and the
narrative is being set right now okay on
the one side there's a narrative that I
have put forward which is that
government basically sucks at everything
they are late on everything they don't
do the things they are supposed to do
and it's a bipartisan failing because
when we have a giant lumbering
which is the government the best you can
hope
for is that they respond in slow and
delayed fashion and in powerful fashion
and you need that's happen sometimes but
to expect that the government is ever
going to be a government that moves with
alacrity and quickness and that the
government is always going to force the
every crisis and that government is ever
good at this stuff that is wrong and the
reason that's important is because
people are trying to extend pandemic
politics to non pandemic politics
they're trying to say well if only the
right people have been running this
thing it all we've been fine which
demonstrates that if the right people
ran government everything would be fine
government could control everything now
quick note when I say that this is a
bipartisan failing that everyone failed
here and again there are a few
exceptions like Senator Tom cotton was
on this thing early Chris Murphy was on
this thing early from Connecticut but
with very few exceptions everyone
botched this thing I'm not even talking
just about the United States Boris
Johnson just locked this thing down like
a weekend like a week ago in the UK
Italy was late on this thing which is
why their hospitals were completely
overrun Spain was late on this thing
which is why their hospitals were
completely overrun France was late on
this thing which is why their deaths per
million population is higher than those
in the United States okay so this is not
just a bipartisan failing this is a
failing of government government is not
perfect government is staffed by
incompetent people and even competent
people who are there have to work
through bureaucracies government is not
all Melling government is not
all-powerful government is a blunt force
instrument and sometimes you need blunt
force instruments like in a global
pandemic understood but the case the
Democrats have been trying to make is
that it's all Trump and if Democrats
have been in charge of this would have
been perfect which demonstrates that in
the time of non pandemic politics if we
just put Democrats in charge all ills
will be solved this has never been true
it will never be true so they're
launching investigations instead trying
to undermine Trump's 2020 reelect
campaign that's what's going on and
they're trying to set the narrative
early that if only Joe Biden or Barack
Obama or Hillary Clinton had been in
charge all of this would have been
avoided we're gonna go through the
timeline I'm gonna demonstrate to you
that this is just not true this is just
not true and we can go through it in a
fair bit of detail in just one second
first if you are sitting at home and you
are not on camera every day like I am
perhaps you are giving that quarantine
beard a shot I know that Colten over
here is given the quarantine beard a
shot you already know it's not as easy
as it looks because beards can dry out
they can get itchy they can look kind of
dumb depending on if you can't grow a
very nice thick beard beard supply
Geert supplies what you need it helps
keep your beard healthy itch free soft
smelling grape more than ten thousand
beards agree beard supply products are
the best there are ten thousand beards
can't be wrong can they each beard
supply beard oil is hand crafted from
100% natural ingredients no synthetics
no mass-market essentials no sulfates no
paraphernalia 1975 which apparently was
a historically amazing smelling year
join jacob Paul and thousands of other
bearded guys are enjoying softer better
smelling less itchy beers I have no idea
who Jacob and Paul are but they probably
have amazing beers for a short time
beard supply is offering a Ben Shapiro
show listeners 25% off just go to beard
supply calm use promo code Shapiro again
that is beard supply.com use promo code
Shapiro beard supply.com promo code
Shapiro okay so in just a second I'm
going to get to the Democrats who are
now launching investigations from the
House Select Committee on the
coronavirus response in the middle of
the pandemic like there's plenty of time
to do this in like I don't know wait six
weeks but they're gonna do it right now
because it is top priority that we blame
Trump as fast as possible which is what
this is gonna come down to even though
we all know what this really is right
once then there will be a 9/11
Commission style report and what it will
find is that years in advance years in
advance there were systemic failures
because this what happened in 9/11 and
then there were warnings that were not
properly heated and then the warnings
were not taken seriously enough and in
hindsight we should have been able to
see that somebody's gonna fly a plane
into the WTO into the World Trade Center
into the WTC but it turns out that in
actual time it's difficult to tell that
warning from the thousand other warnings
coming across your desk and that when
you are faced with the prospect of
exponential growth and you haven't even
seen the evidence yet because China's
lying about it it turns out that if
you're two weeks late it makes a big big
difference but those are human mistakes
not somebody who is sitting there
deliberately saying I want millions of
Americans to die right it'll look
exactly like the 9/11 report but
Democrats are intent on politicizing
this thing like right now right now and
driving that narrative that I talked
about before which is that in the end
government could be incredible at this
government could be if you just put
Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi in
if you just put Joe Biden who's not even
alive in charge of the government then
all of this could have been prevented
now we're gonna get to more of this in
just one second first you should go over
right now and subscribe to Taylor why
how come why should you do this well one
reason you should do this is because we
have all access live right all access
live is something we just launched we
accelerated the launch of it was
originally meant for as the name
suggests all access members it is now
available to everyone basically one of
our hosts hangs out with you every night
we just hang out together it's very
casual and fun we just answer questions
and hang out and spend time with one
another in our apartment
a sense of community is pretty important
at times like this I've been doing them
twice a week I believe I'm doing one
tomorrow night right before Shabbat
tonight I believe it's Andrew Clavin so
you can hang out with Andrew and hear
him make pretentious literary references
and you know you can you can watch as he
attempts to escape coronavirus being
part of the target group so basically is
like a suspense novel except in real
time you can see if Clavin kills over in
the the show is intended for our
all-access members during this national
emergency in time of isolation we've
opened it up to all our members go
subscribe right now at Daley wire.com
and come hang out with us you're
listening to the largest fastest core
and conservative podcast and radio show
in the nation
[Music]
you
okay so the breaking news this morning
is that Nancy Pelosi is creating a House
Select Committee on coronavirus it'll be
chaired by Jim Clyburn so we're gonna do
impeachment
all over again good times House
Democrats on Wednesday had called for
the creation of an independent panel to
investigate the Trump administration's
response to coronal virus once the
pandemic subsides we didn't wait for
half a minute Maya Nancy Pelosi is
already setting up a Select Committee
investigation with Jim Clyburn heading
it represented Bennie Thompson Democrat
of Mississippi chairman of the Homeland
Security Committee said it's clear that
we as a nation are at another inflection
point Americans today will again demand
a full accounting of how prepared we
were how we responded to this global
public health emergency Americans will
need answers on how our government can
work better to prevent a similar crisis
from happening again okay here's the
answer you want to know the answer the
answer is that you know what is one of
the key things key that keeps people
alive in a pandemic now be ventilators
and you know what people have been
warned about for literally decades lack
of insulators you know government
completely ignored the ventilators you
know what it turns out people need in
times of pandemic and 95 masks you know
any times that stockpile was blown
through and not read and not resourced a
fair number of times you know what that
we're gonna find we're gonna find that
governors state governors local mayors
didn't do the job they were supposed to
do in warning people we're gonna find
out that our policy with regard to China
was a complete failure we're gonna find
out a lot of things you know we're not
going to find out that if President
Trump had not been president then all
this would have magically been solved
that's what we're not gonna find out but
that is exactly what Democrats are gonna
try and pitch right Adam Schiff who was
busy distracting the entire nation
throughout January on impeachment he
said after Pearl Harbor 9/11 we've
looked at what went wrong to learn from
our mistakes once we've recovered
we need a nonpartisan Commission for a
view our response and how we can better
prepare for the next pandemic now I'm
not saying that the Trump administration
should have been distracted by
impeachment they shouldn't have they
should be able to walk and chew gum at
the same time but I don't remember Adam
Schiff saying three words about
coronavirus in January to you it was all
impeachment all the time
right it was all impeachment all the
time and I also remember there's some
fairly important dates throughout this
is that like for example my February 4th
you remember President Trump spoke at
the at the State of the Union address as
she mentioned coronavirus and Nancy
Pelosi tore up the paper and then you
recall that we had a bunch of primary
debates coronaviruses asked about like
one time a couple times people were
holding rallies okay I'm gonna go
through the timeline now so let's go
through the timeline exactly how this
how this thing went forward so how did
this thing get screwed up so badly well
let's start with the these stuff from
years ago that were supposed to ignore
so the federal stockpile of n95
respirator masks the shortage of it can
be traced back to 2009 after the h1n1
swine flu pandemic when the Obama
administration was advised to replenish
the national stockpile but did not
according to reports from both Bloomberg
News and the LA Times The Washington
Examiner reporting the Trump
administration is scrambling to
replenish a stockpile of protective
medical gear for health care workers and
patients as coronavirus freepursuits
weeps across the nation and 95
respirator masks are one of the most
needed medical supplies amid the
outbreak the George W Bush
administration published the national
strategy for pandemic influenza plan in
2005 it called on the feds to distribute
medical supplies from the National
strategic stockpile governed by the HHS
in the event of an outbreak in 2009
there was an outbreak it led to 274,000
hospitalizations and nearly 13,000
deaths and a depletion of the respirator
masks a federally best tact federally
backed task force and safety equipment
organization both recommended to the
Obama administration the stockpile be
replenished with a hundred million masks
used after the h1n1 outbreak instead
that did not happen instead there was
basically no refilling of the inventory
okay so that's a failure right these
failures and again I'm not saying that
the Republicans would've done better
here I'm saying everyone screws stuff up
all the time that's the nature of
government
welcome to the actuality about
government government is not your savior
government can act in crucial situations
to stop the incoming bullet by throwing
your body in front of it but government
or your job in front of it more
important you know more and more
accurately but government is not perfect
government makes mistakes Black Swan
events take governments by surprise
we've had Black Swan events under every
president and they've always taken the
government by surprise because guess
what government and god and staffed by
human people hey other elements that are
gonna come into play
in at least ten government reports from
2003 to 2015 federal officials predicted
the US would experience a critical lack
of ventilators and other life-saving
medical devices if it faced a viral
outbreak like the one currently sweeping
the country the drumbeat of warnings
undermines president Trump's claim and
nobody in their wildest dreams could
have imagined the demand
ventilators that now exist but it also
undermines by the way that CNN reporting
it also undermines the narrative that
everybody did a wonderful job up until
Trump of replenishing the ventilator
stockpile if we had dozens of reports
over the course of 12 years when Donald
Trump was not president to replenish the
ventilator stockpile and nobody did it
then how is that Trump's fault exactly
exclusively he should've done it but he
wasn't president for like the 15 years
preceding his presidency I mean and the
list goes on and on report in May 2003
November 2005 another one from November
2005 July 2006 August 2006 November 2007
2009 OSHA publication August 2009 2015
study from the DHHS and the CDC okay so
that's a lot of failures is it not okay
so is that exclusively on Obama or Bush
or Trump or is this how disasters happen
okay so now let's look at the more
modern timeline here so some people took
this seriously early and some people did
not okay so let's talk about who took
this seriously pretty early so Lamar
Alexander took this took this seriously
early political reported this like just
a few days ago on January 24th fourth at
the urging of senator Lamar Alexander
Republican of Tennessee administration
officials held a briefing for the full
Senate the classified session was
sparsely attended according to to Senate
aides it was put together at the last
minute it was held on the same day as a
deadline for senators to submit their
impeachment questions very important
stuff only about 14 senators showed up
for the briefing for the full Senate on
coronavirus on January 24th 14 senators
senator Lamar Alexander was there the
initial thought from the Dems I think as
we were trying to distract from
impeachment said GOP Senate aide a White
House official Recaro recalled feeling
surprised this Politico feeling
surprised at the incredibly poor
attendance noting and came even though
the amount of concern expressed then was
rather intense Alexander then issued a
bland statement saying we're monitoring
the outbreak of coronavirus then people
started increasing their warnings but
the warnings again the statements that
are made better than the statements that
Trump made by a number of officials
including Chuck Schumer but the actual
measures that were calling for are not
even in the same week as what we have
actually done here they're not in the
same league as what if as what would
have been necessary
so again
expressions are nice tweets are nice
saying things good better than saying
the wrong things are putting out
misinformation about how this is just
like the flu 100% but number one a lot
of people in the left on the Left we're
saying this was just like the flu
including the Washington Post as of
early February including voxcom as of
late January and beyond that let's be
real about this you saying this is not
like the flu and then proposing as Chuck
Schumer did to spend 85 million dollars
in funding for federal agencies and I
guess that solves the problem that does
not count as you being sufficiently
concerned that counts as you being more
concerned than Trump was but I don't use
president Trump's level of concern as
the bar for everything would have been
okay if you had been in charge that's
not where the bar lies and January 26th
according to Politico Senate Minority
Leader Chuck Schumer called on the
Department of Health and Human Services
to declare coronavirus a public health
emergency
that would have 85 million dollars in
funding for federal agencies in January
28th patty maria maria cantwell the
washington state two Democratic senators
already Washington state was being hit
by this demand in January 20th letter
that Secretary of Health and Human
Services Alexei czar keep them apprised
with the latest information regarding
the severity of the disease the
country's capacity to diagnose cases
what steps were being taken to prepare
US health care workers but screening
systems were in place there were only
five cases of corona virus discovered in
the United States at that time and by
the way
patty maria maria cantwell i'm sorry a
demand letter saying i want more
information it's not quite the same
thing as let's shut down the entire
American economy for two weeks let's
make sure that we have millions of tests
available again no one foresaw what this
was going to take this does not mean the
Trump administration did a wonderful job
it means everyone sucks at this not in
equal levels but everyone was sucky okay
and no one was going to prevent the the
levels of insanity that we are now
seeing in terms of public policy on
January sort of and let's look at this
timeline right so Joe Biden has been
pitching this op-ed that he wrote
January 27th about coronavirus he's been
saying well this shows that I took
things super seriously a lot of his
allies been saying this so let's look at
that at that op-ed so he says that
President Trump is a bad person to lead
our country through a global health
challenge and he talks about how the and
in that article in that article he talks
about how it was bad to stop people from
crossing borders quote diseases do not
stop at borders they cannot be
awarded by building a wall we cannot
keep others safe without helping to keep
others safe as well and without listing
the help of other nations in return and
then he talked about what he was going
to do right so people like well Joe
Biden proposed solutions they say
Elizabeth Warren also had a plan yeah
Elizabeth plan had Elizabeth Warren you
may remember her campaign had a plan for
lesbian Inuit Inuit dock workers right
she had a plan for everything the
question is were the plans actually
sufficient and the answer was no because
nobody was talking about the kinds of
measures that would eventually be put in
place here is what Joe Biden suggests
that as his plan is in this January 27th
op-ed he keeps referring to again you
saying coronavirus is a problem in
January 27th is better then Trump sort
of play pretending it wasn't a problem
as of January 27 for sure but it doesn't
mean that you handling the reins of
government would have done anything like
what was necessary in order to stop this
thing if Donald Trump had proposed on
January 27th we need a two-week shutdown
of the entire American economy also
we're going to need two trillion dollars
in spending also we're gonna need four
trillion dollars for the for the Federal
Reserve to disperse and the Treasury
Department how you think that would have
gone in late January we were all alive
then most of us so um I think that you
recall that would not have gone
particularly well so what did you buy
him propose on January 27th what did he
propose he suggested he suggested that
what we ought to do was spend more money
on international institutions here's
what he says he says we brought the
world together behind the responses
about Ebola that only the US could
mobilize we dispatched our military on a
limited mission to help build the urgent
infrastructure necessary to coordinate a
massive global public health response we
deployed to disaster assistance response
teams we unleashed the NIH we
contributed two billion dollars to
international institutions what does any
of this sound like what was necessary at
the same time the Joe Biden was saying
this stuff publicly Joe Biden was also
saying that was a very bad idea to to
ban travel from China and he was saying
that was xenophobic and cruel to do so
now the only people I'm aware of who
actually we're talking about the kinds
of solutions that were necessary where
Scott Gottlieb you know the Scott
Gottlieb wrote a piece this would have
been in in January twenty-eighth Scott
was
Gottlieb and Luciana borio wrote some op
eds talking about actual suggestions
have been early february talk about how
we need massive levels of testing how we
need surveillance systems like all the
stuff that we actually need that was
picked up by no politician no politician
picked up on that none okay so the stuff
they were talking about Chuck Schumer
talked about freeing up 85 million
dollars which is like we just spent a
vast multiple of that and Joe Biden
talking about how we need to fully fund
the CDC when we did fully fund the CDC
but what the Washington Post on February
first wrote a piece saying that flu was
the biggest threat that's literally the
title of an article from the Washington
Post
get a grip America the flu is a much
bigger threat than coronavirus before
now I Lenny Bernstein in their health
section right so so again I think it's
we need to be accurate about the
timeline here which is that when it
comes to the measures necessary I'm not
talking about the general level of
seriousness where he said yes I think
coronavirus will be a problem I'm
talking about the what needs to be done
which is what you're supposed to do in
government no one except for Scott
Gottlieb in borio we're talking about
the necessaries no one was talking about
this maybe you had Tom cotton who was
taking this more seriously again Chris
Murphy tweeted something out where he
was taking this seriously and I want to
mention this because some people were
taking this more serious like Chris
Murphy he tweeted out just left the
administration briefing on coronavirus
bottom line they aren't taking this
seriously enough this is February 5th
notably no requests for any emergency
funding which is a big mistake local
health systems need supplies training
screaming staff etc they needed it now
ok well Chuck Schumer had said the
previous week we need 85 million dollars
is that what Chris Murphy was talking
about like I'm glad that he expressed
concern and expressions of concern are
not worth very much by the way even
Donald Trump amidst his bizarrely
chaotic response to coronavirus even he
was making expressions of concern
remember Trump didn't mention during his
State of the Union coronavirus while
Nancy Pelosi was zoning out this from
February 4th protecting Americans health
also means fighting infectious diseases
we are coordinating with the Chinese
government and working closely together
on the corona virus outbreak in China my
administration will take all necessary
steps to safeguard our citizens from
this threat later of course the Nancy
Pelosi would tear up that speech and say
that it was a miasma of information from
and a complete pack of lies the truth is
everyone was counting on the CDC to
handle this thing right
they didn't the CDC blew it in vast and
incredible ways by the way speaking of
people who didn't take this seriously
the Huffington Post
had a piece January 31st titled don't
listen to Senator Tom cotton about
coronavirus don't listen to Senator Tom
cotton about coronavirus saying that was
xenophobic right again
the Washington Post claimed that it was
the flu Vox com claimed it was the flu
this is late January then as time moved
forward let's look at the actual
timeline okay the actual timeline here
let's flashback to the Democratic
debates these were happening all
throughout February what was the sort of
laser-like focus that supposedly would
have prevented all of this here is Joe
Biden who supposedly was taking the
super series it's a month after his
op-ed okay he was asked about
coronavirus in the February 25th
democratic debate here was his answer
about what he would do with coronavirus
by the way this is like two weeks before
we went on national lockdown essentially
here was Joe Biden February 25th
he cut the funding for CDC he tried to
cut the funding for NIH he cut the
funding for the entire effort and here's
the deal I would be on the phone with
China and making it clear we are going
to need to be in your country weird I
don't hear any of the measures that have
now been taken coming out of the mouth
of Joe Biden I just AM yelling about how
Trump by the way did not cut the funding
to the CDC he proposed a cuts of funding
to the CDC that did not go through
meanwhile where were the Democrats
criticizing you know actual mayors in
charge of the crisis in the biggest
hotspot on planet Earth New York City
all right let's just flash back for a
second to Mayor Bill DeBlasio and his
health leaders over in New York City and
by the way Nancy Pelosi as of February
24th okay this is all the way in the
middle of February when supposedly
everyone except from post hanging and
super seriously here are all these
Democrats in and when people say well
put aside the Blasio how do you put
aside the mayor of the town where all
the deaths are happening right here is
Mayor Bill de Blasio and a bunch of his
local health officials CERN at this time
for coronavirus in our region the
Department of Sanitation is ready for
Mardi Gras 2020 the facts are reassuring
we want New Yorkers to go about their
daily lives there's really no need to
panic and to avoid activities that we
always do as New Yorkers we are Hardy
people Americans do not need to panic
what I would say
however is that Americans take this as a
wake-up call for seasonal flu
okay so wake-up call for seasonal this
is what officials were saying okay so
before we pretend that Donald Trump was
the only person who was missing the boat
here or the Trump administration were
the only people who were missing the
boat that is not true number two even if
you weren't missing the boat and you
said coronavirus is a problem none of
you we're proposing the kind of response
that was necessary only Gottlieb as far
as I'm aware was proposing publicly the
kinds of responses that were necessary
on February 26th Congress offered eight
point three billion dollars to Trump for
for all this stuff Trump said I want 1.5
billion to two billion dollars and Chuck
Schumer tweeted out that we want to give
all sorts of new funding like eight
point three billion dollars Republicans
were saying we want that to be not
unfunded right we want to take that
money from other places and Chuck
Schumer was fighting them on it and
President Trump then came out and he
said if you give us the money we'll take
the money right wouldn't give us the
money for the wall but you'll give us
the money for this so I guess we'll take
the money I'll take care of states
because states are working very hard we
have hospitals and states that make
rooms available and they they're
building quarantine areas areas where
you can keep people safely we're working
really well with States it's a very big
part of it so you know my attitude if
Congress wants to give us the money so
easy wasn't very easy for the wall but
we got that one done if they want to
give us the money and we'll take the
money we'll just do a good job with it
okay so he wasn't rejecting the money
and in fact he ended up signing into law
a bill but only on March 6th because
Nancy Pelosi was too busy trying to use
that bill to strip protections for n95
mask makers not kidding you
okay so that bill was proposed in late
February it took until early March to
pass that bill why why because Nancy
Pelosi didn't want to waive consumer
rights to sue a company over potentially
faulty equipment so Republicans were
arguing we should relieve liability so
companies will produce this stuff faster
and we can get it out faster and Nancy
Pelosi was too busy worrying about the
trial lawyers right Deb Fischer put
forward a bill in early March a bill
with bipartisan backing they would
protect makers of respirators like 3m
from lawsuits if the companies produce
masks upon federal government requests
according to a Senate GOP aide every
time we tried to pass that fisher's bill
the trial lawyers were the first ones
out blocking it that refused to
negotiate with us Democratic leaders
tried to hold this thing up for like a
week
Pelosi won applause these days had
I should mask makers have special
immunity we'll try and get these things
out the door and Nancy Pelosi's worried
about how people can sue other people so
clearly everyone acting with the great
sense of urgency we have been told
everyone had except for President Trump
okay so how long did it take for
everybody to respond to this thing and
March forth Seattle officials
recommended that high-risk residents
stay at home over coronavirus in King
County and Snohomish counties that is
because the chief sensor of the outbreak
at the time was in Seattle that was in
mao's on March 4th 2020 Olivia message
reported that for The Daily Beast the
sub headline was don't panic okay and
then what happened next well March 4th
was also Super Tuesday if you recall
millions of people across the country
came out and voted there was no talk on
Super Tuesday I was there I remember
there's not a lot to talk about the
risks being taken on Super Tuesday to
vote in primaries instead the questions
were about the results that was all the
media coverage Joe Biden was still
holding rallies Donald Trump was still
holding rallies Bernie Sanders was still
holding rallies they were all going out
in public they were all discussing
whether or not they should continue to
hold those rallies on March 6th Trump
signed that eight point three billion
dollar relief package on March 8th LA
mayor Eric Garcetti did not cancel the
LA Marathon
I remember being bizarrely puzzled by
this sort of thing because I had I'll
tell you on a personal level I'd started
getting much more serious about looking
into this in late February one seemed
like a lot of the notes were getting
pretty bad and I wrote a piece on March
6 talking about the fatality rates from
coronavirus which by the way was
accurate on the data and what I
basically said is it may not be as
deadly as people are making it out to be
but I was certainly concerned about the
transmission rate of the virus okay so
as of like I can tell you in fact the
exact date because I remember it the
exact date where it finally dawned on me
this thing was gonna be a disaster area
and that was March basically March 10th
right around that weekend so I remember
thinking okay people are saying this is
really serious but Mayor Eric Garcetti
is just letting 20,000 people run in the
street and spit on each other right
27,000 people ran in the LA Marathon and
you know what Eric Garcetti said about
this he said quote there's no reason to
cancel it that was March 6th don't tell
me everybody was super serious about
this stuff in late January or throughout
February it's just not true right I'm
March 6th they allowed this to go
forward that was Eric Garcetti on March
6th
I remember I got super serious about
this the so my baby was born March 4th
we got out of the hospital sort of that
weekend we were concerned about it and
then poor him which was Jewish holiday
happened a little bit later that week is
like March 10th and I remember that we
went to that there was talk already by
March 10th about shutting down the
services like should you go to services
or not and we went to services that day
and then there was a party down the
block like a house party and I remember
saying to my parents I really don't
think we should be going to this house
party that was when I started getting
serious enough that it was like we
started self limiting on a social level
okay and then it took like another that
was March 10th that took another week
for San Francisco to issue a stay at
home order the stay at home order that
started this whole thing you know in
terms of like very strict measures March
16th is when the stay at home order
happened I believe that we at daly wire
told all of our own workers to go home
as in March 16th I think it has been a
couple weeks right so it's I think I
think it was that week that we told
people at daly wire that if they can
work from home they should absolutely
work from home California more broadly
issued a stay at home order the broad
stay at home order that was March 19th
right so if everybody was taking the
super seriously why were these orders
not being emanated like early March the
beginning of March and where was all the
where was all the protests at Bill
DeBlasio again Bill de Blasio's being an
idiot for like months at a time
where was he where was all the criticism
March in New York did not issue New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo did not issue a
stay at home order until March 20th
March 20th so for all the talk about
yeah we were all taking it super
seriously except for Trump
you guys are governors of states and
mayors of towns and you are members of
Congress and you are the Speaker of the
House I don't remember
trillion-dollar packages I don't
remember tens of billions of dollars
being spent on filling the ventilator
requests I don't require I don't
remember the I don't remember this great
sense of tremendous urgency kicking in
until early March now again that is not
to alleviate responsibility on Trump for
downplaying the Sangh which I think he
did do I think you down I think he
downplayed it through February I think
that's true
I think Tucker Carlson was was
instrumental in awakening the president
on a personal level to how dangerous
this thing was but to pretend as the
Democrats surely will that everybody was
on top of this thing
for Trump and that Congress can be
trusted and that everyone can be trusted
and that everything is humming on March
11th AOC was going on her Instagram and
telling people that it was racist not to
eat at Chinese restaurants on March 11th
I mean come on but just come on come on
oh yeah that like the timeline exists
you cannot reverse the timeline just
because you wish that the narrative were
different okay time for let's do a quick
thing that I hate I suppose China
continues to be the world's most
horrible actor I feel like I feel like
Biff in Back to the Future you just did
300 bucks damaged my car you son of a
and now I'm gonna take it out of
your ass right that's right that's what
I feel about China right now you have
destroyed the world economy it will cost
the world economy ten trillion dollars
15 trillion dollars endless amounts of
money to come at us and you've cost the
world tens of thousands of lives
meanwhile China is getting aggressive
militarily we're supposed to treat them
like they're our friends according to
the Asia Times China seizes Cova 19
advantage in the South China Sea with
the Kovan 19 pandemic mostly contained
in China and now wreaking havoc on the
United States security analysts are
closely watching Beijing's military
moves and the hotly contested South
China Sea in recent days China has
conducted military drills and deployed
large-scale military assets to the
maritime area while at the same time
officially celebrating strides made in
exploiting disputed energy resources in
the fossil fuel rich sea while some see
China's nationalistic message as a bid
to rally its people others view the
increasingly aggressive naval maneuvers
as a bid to exploit America's weakened
condition to secure new advantage in the
hot spot theater so taking advantage of
the fact that we just had to remove a
carrier basically from circulation
thanks to corona virus infections
they're taking advantage of all of this
in order to get aggressive on the world
stage not a shock the Philippines and
Malaysia both the territorial
loggerheads with China in the sea have
both recently placed their
administration and commercial
capitalists under weeks long military
enforced lock down the US the long term
guarantor of the region's law-based
order is now grappling with the world's
worst outbreak the Pentagon has been
mobilized to help out at home China is
moving to capitalize meanwhile this has
gone hand in hand with attempts to drive
a diplomatic wedge between the US and
its traditional transatlantic
some of which have remained recently
committed some of which have recently
committed naval vessels so us-led
freedom of navigation operations in the
South China Sea
so Beijing is putting out propaganda
trying to blame the United States for
all of this meanwhile if they had not
lied about this for a month over a month
and commanded the WH er to do their
bidding there'd be a lot more people
alive today and there and certainly a
lot more preventable deaths would have
been prevented
good for the Japanese vice prime
minister he came out and he said the wh
oh the World Health Organization should
be renamed the Chinese Health
Organization we're gonna have to
radically rethink how we do business
with the w-h-o radically rethink this
thing it's a disaster area international
institutions cannot be run by the
world's worst players while we flip the
bell it's horrifying I mean I wish I
honest-to-god wish there were a way for
us to cancel the debt that we owe to
China there is no way to do it because
the face bonds don't actually have on it
signed to China on there but we're gonna
have to take strict measures in the
future with how we deal with China China
is not just a geopolitical enemy they're
a rogue state that is a danger to
everyone in the world they hid this
thing for a month
they allowed five million Wu hen
residents to go out and move around
freely in the world without telling
anybody they lied to the w-h-o as of
January 14th the w-h-o was still
maintaining publicly that there was no
human human transmission of this thing
wrecked the world economy I mean it's
just it's unbelievable
meanwhile the one of my favorite things
is the is the Chinese government trying
to put out propaganda suggesting that
its US military operations in the South
China Sea that are increasing the risk
of confrontation according to a Beijing
based think tanks shocker u.s.
intensified its military activity in the
South China Sea last year raising the
risk of confrontation with China so
China's trying to put out the notice
that as it gets more aggressive in the
South China Sea because everybody else
is busy dealing with the pandemic they
just unleashed from their own country
the Chinese government that it's
everybody else's aggression that is it
that is pissing off the Chinese so the
South China Morning Post which to the
best of my understanding is a is a
Chinese official publication or semi
official publication says the US
conducted eight so-called freedom of
navigation operations in the year three
more than in 2018 during which its
vessels sailed within 12 nautical miles
of land claimed or occupied by China
according to the South China Sea
strategic situation probing initiatives
annual report American force is also
engaged in at least 50 joint and
multiple exercises with countries from
Southeast Asia and elsewhere in the
region how provocative how insanely
provocative yet probably it's the u.s.
provocation that is responsible for all
of this probably probably this is this
is the problem by the way you know about
those shortages of supply that we've had
in masks that's not because we didn't
contract for the masks it's because all
the supply chains ran through China you
know what China did when they needed the
masks you seize the supplies you know
all the drugs that people are looking to
get you know I'm talking about like
everyday drugs not even coronavirus
drugs a lot of those are produced in
China the supply chains have been
disrupted China deserves to have its ass
kicked on an international stage if not
militarily then financially I mean this
is just what a disaster area that
government is we we should all pray for
a for a a major change of government in
that region to free a billion people
from the servitude under which the
Chinese government has placed them just
astonishing astonishing stuff by the way
good news Shenzhen just became the first
Chinese city to ban eating cats and dogs
oh good I'm glad I'm glad that they
finally gotten on this thing about like
not eating the cats and not eating the
dogs good good stuff apparently Chinese
authorities had supposedly banned the
trade and consumption of wild animals
but they are continuing to lie about
that apparently what markets are still
open and China they've also been lying
about the number of people who are dead
there they've been lying about reopening
industry that is all why this is a rogue
state a rogue state alright so we'll be
back here a little bit later today with
two additional hours of content
otherwise we'll be back here for all of
your updates tomorrow hang in there I
know this is rough it's rough for
everybody the news is gonna get rougher
over the next two weeks
stick with us we'll bring it all to you
we'll go through it in a reasonable
fashion and remember in the end in the
end America remains the greatest country
on Earth not because the government is
so spectacular things it remains great
because Americans are great because
Americans care for each other because
we're looking out for each other with
that said continue the social distancing
continue to wear masks if you got in
publics you know a coffin on other
people are breathing on other people
continue to do all the things that are
necessary to bring this to an end so we
can all get back to work make the
economy boom again and then and then
move forward to a more successful future
hopefully a future in which we certainly
rethink our
relations with places like China and
international institutions that are
become cat's-paws of the Chinese
government all right we'll be back here
later today or we'll see you here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh show it's not
just another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you